yo kwazy what's the verdict you gonna
sell your car
[Music]
and I'm see producers if you don't know
about Los Angeles is one of the most
car-dependent cities in America so my
cheap traffic so for the next 30 days
we're both in additional car but first
one big question is it worth owning a
car let's go solve all your
transportation needs I'm gonna live with
three generations of Brooklyn yourself
three generations of Brooklyn
ok so made it to work we're here there's
my lips pulling off he's great out here
uptime another beautiful day taking lift
I could get used to this so it appears
that we've been using the lift credits
wrong that's what I've been doing
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
instead of taking a lift directly to
work this time I took a train it's way
cheaper way faster and more convenient
if you use and live for your final
alright so made it off the bus and I am
going to call over live alright the
office 9:00 on the dot
committed to work just on time so one of
the setbacks of not all our new cars
running small errors like going to the
grocery store but since I don't have a
car the plan is final lift school that
actually wasn't that hard so I'm going
to Costco today for a grocery and
supplies haul and since I don't have a
car I rented a Zipcar which was super
easy all right let's take a break and
talk about car ownership according to a
2017 study by Triple A the average new
car costs eight thousand four hundred
and sixty nine dollars per year this
includes the same
that seems pretty expensive for a new
car right in the US drivers spend an
average of 55 minutes in two cars each
day this might seem like a lot but
consider that there are 1440 minutes in
a day that means your car is only used
for about 4% of the day I walked to work
my lift has been two minutes away for
what feels like five minutes
I am a full hour early because this guy
got lost so many times where the is this
guy it's been it's been more than it's
been forever
this whole video now is getting pretty
annoying just wanna get in my own car
and drive home
I don't know
so it's the end of the 30-day lip
challenge and I've decided I'm gonna
sell this fan because honestly the
upkeep costs way more than it's worth
got my title and my keys what I took
from this experience is that owning a
car is truly priceless the fact of the
matter is you can just hop in and go
wherever you want whenever you want but
the cost of maintenance due to repairs
which are such a headache to deal with I
don't want to go through it again today
is my last day of being a car owner one
thing I don't want to do is pay for a
car that's just sitting there for
majority of the day what LIF is trying
to do is definitely I open it you've
treated me well it's time to give it up
goodbye I have nothing but good things
to say about you it's time for us to
separation
[Music]